on Sunday the all-star game is also
dedicated to Ernie Johnson and Ernie I
hope you don't mind there is gonna be a
tribute video to me in the second
quarter I hope that's okay to you I'm
not aware of that of being part of the
all-star festivities so I would be
totally uncomfortable I think that I
should belong to Paul Pierce this should
be I mean what do you make of all this
Ernie I mean come on I I think number
one that there are you know we're pretty
hasty and in making tribute videos but I
but you know I think it's a special
thing when you're talking about Isaiah
Thomas and what he went through last
year and what he meant to that team so
he he certainly deserves one and I I
just you know the whole thing with you
know is it whose night is it hey come on
or can we can we not grow up can we not
get past that can we can we can we not
make it all about us please there you go
that's my answer well cuz to me you know
what what skin is off or anybody's nose
if there's like a 45 60 second video in
a second yeah I mean it's not gonna hurt
it's not gonna take away from anybody's
night I think you know I think the two
could probably the two things could
coexist I mean in if they come on please
all right let's put that aside and talk
about things that are more important
like guys storming locker rooms Ernie
[Laughter]
what are we coming to I mean but you
know it's it was what was funny was
being in the middle of the reaction from
from the guys on my set oh my goodness
gracious
Ernest because you know here's rose gold
on woody is doing doing her job and
trying to fill us in on exactly what
happened because there was a lot going
on on Twitter and loge was out there and
everybody's trying to describe what's
going on and so we just kind of wanted
the answer and I would be perfectly
content to leave it there but when when
the police presence was was required
that's what set Charles and Shaq off and
so then it was I had lost total control
until those guys had their say we
weren't going anywhere and it's yeah and
I'm not surprised to see that some
suspensions are there you can't you
can't have this you know going down you
can't have you can't have guys going
another guy's locker room looking for
trouble early or who's gonna be a
peacemaker and who's looking for trouble
I don't know so yeah it was it was it
was a memorable evening for sure but we
will not be seeing trevor ariza tonight
on our air no but there will be a
tribute video to him a locker room I
think five seconds I hastily introduced
but but high-quality normal rice with
with Clint capela banging on the door
saying to press play and you know by the
way it's funny because I watch TV in a
different way and I watched that with
you sitting in the middle of that I have
been there before with goat analysts
cackling and you as the host need them
to kind of stop laughing to explain to
people at home why they're laughing yeah
and then Kenny Smith was kind of the
interpreter in real-time of explain Terp
reting there left it was I think my only
input was look I'm sure that there were
no Clippers who called the police to say
that there were Rockets trying to get
into our locker room you know I'm sure
that this was some security folks is
that this is outside of our reach we
need some reinforcements or whatever but
yeah it's just silly and it all happened
on MLK Day I know adding to the adding
to the just the the nature of the whole
Turner Sports CJ Ernie Johnson here on
the Rich Eisen show so okay to me though
in all seriousness there is an issue
between the reps and the players correct
there's no question about it
and rich what I was trying to remember I
thought a few years ago that there was
an initiative by the league and by the
league's officials to say look we you
guys need to need to take more you need
to have more of a smile on your face and
let guys have their say and then and now
it seems to have have kind of gone the
other way and and and the triggers are
pretty quick and and so yeah I
understand that there's going to be a me
between the you know the league and the
officials and the players and and and
try to get this thing straightened out
but it you know it it really doesn't do
anybody any good when it's to have a lot
of animosity in that relationship these
guys got to coexist on the floor for 48
minutes and and I think and I think you
know everybody needs to have a little
more patience oh I think you know it's
gone from the league saying you can't
you can't show any demonstration if
you're a player you know member remember
and they were they were throwing T's out
like crazy several years ago if a guy
just rolled his eyes no you can't have
any reaction to what the officials are
saying and there's and then they're
saying well you're taking the emotion
out of it and that it was okay well
let's have the officials be a little
more tolerant and not so quick to to
whistle and now it's just like who knows
what's gonna happen
so yes something needs to be done it's
and some talks have to be had you know I
mean last night there was a technical
called
on Lee for the Knicks that was pretty
crucial it was right when it was a jump
ball three point game he gets one even
though there were two guys getting into
it and part of this to me you know Ernie
I don't know I talked about it with John
Barry yesterday is is there a connection
between the short fuses that players
have each with each other because they
they're they're angered by the
officiating and maybe some of them feel
like they have to police things by
themselves because they're not trusting
the officials to do it I'm wondering if
everything's connected what we're yeah I
guess I guess yeah to an extent and I
you know and I think that you know the
officials on their part are trying to
keep you know something from going on
because if something does get out of
hand then people are saying well the
officials should have seen that coming
and they should have done something
about it
earlier and now when you try to do
something to defuse it then now you're
getting the other you know you're going
to the other extreme so yeah let's let's
let's let's sit down let's talk let's
let's get to a common ground and and
carry on but you can't you know you
don't want to see a bunch of games
decided because somebody gets a T in a
real close game when they have really
weren't doing much of anything at all so
then let's get to the actual game how
about that instead of by the way I I
received a technical the other night it
was it was there I was very strange I
called one for me from the floor
into the studio I don't know how it
happened is that real it was it was your
script not in the proper place Ernie
what happened no there was no I was I'm
it's totally in jest and was a pretty
bad line to begin with and it's just
getting worse
so what was your next I was about sailor
on let me just continue that on this if
you were gonna choose somebody on the
set to shoot a free throw on your behalf
it certainly would not be Shaquille
O'Neal no it'd be kitty Kenny would be
the guy without question
Kenny rarely misses on Kenny's court so
yeah I like that so what is the story
first half in the NBA that we're not
talking about nobody's talking about
because we're stuck in everything that
we just discussed or whether whether the
Cavs still have it or what's going on
with the Celtics what are we missing
here I think I think maybe maybe Toronto
would probably say hey how what about us
you know because they've they very
quietly put together a real good first
half of the year so far and and one of
those three games behind Boston right
now so I think you know maybe people are
talking about Toronto enough people are
talking about Minnesota enough probably
you know I really like that young team
and then I think and I think that you
know it's been a long long time since
we've seen them in the playoffs probably
2004 maybe 2005 way back then and so in
there in the Garnett years so yeah I
think I think those would be those would
be two of the stories I think that we
probably don't pay enough attention to
but it's hard to it's hard to not talk
about what's going on with Cleveland and
his LeBron Spain or is he going and is
he unhappy and you know it is just
looking like the the time before he
departed Miami you know and and so I
think you I think you kind of have to
talk about those things a lot of the
people who watch the league are talking
about but yeah don't don't sleep on
Toronto don't sleep on Minnesota but boy
it's looking to me still like a it's
like it's a golden state in the West and
it's and it's unless somebody can find a
way to beat LeBron James four times in a
series and then we may have that same
finals match and how about lights not
sleep on the Spurs we find out Kawhi
Leonard's out indefinitely but they win
their 30th game of the season they beat
Brooklyn last night the 30 wins
by the way PI's Houston for the
second-most in the conference behind
Golden State I mean yes it's it and and
if and if Leonard you know does cost
them a couple of games they would be the
five or six seed nobody wants to see I'm
sure you don't want it you don't want to
play them because the again they're so
sound top-to-bottom no matter who's in
there and then Popovich you know that's
that's the system but no I mean if Kawhi
Leonard's not around though
then in San Antonio is not going to not
going to go anywhere but let's get let's
get props to a guy who's been bashed
over the last year LaMarcus Aldridge
who's who's in my mind having an
all-star year and and he's the he's the
major reason that team is sitting on 30
wins right now all right before I let
you go Ernie you're my you're my Atlanta
whisperer okay you give I mean the way
that the Falcons went out the last two
seasons sandwiched away around the way
Georgia football went out what no cuz no
why why are you doing why are you
bringing Georgia into this I know Ryan
so hard to get over that and and but go
on but it was a hell of a Rose Bowl I
mean I personally witnessed that one
here and then and a great championship
game to look I mean that was I I'm at
the I'm at the mercedes-benz Stadium
with my son Eric and when you know
watching you know just experiencing
every possible emotion you can have in a
sporting event it was it was awesome to
be part of it didn't come out our way
but yeah I mean it was whoa I mean that
was a tremendous game I guess I just
wanted you to give voice to the Atlanta
sports fan that been that that's that's
seen a lot that's all well yeah I don't
think the I don't think the hopes were
as bright this year as they were last
year
going into the playoffs but I think that
I was it has a tough way to go down to
when you you know when you're if you're
favored on the other guys field and and
then you you know you know you don't you
know come up with it but we're all right
we're we're hanging in down there you
know and and the Hawks are are also in
the NBA
at 13 and 31 it's just it's pretty rosy
down here and it snowed this week and
there was ice on the road and but the
Hawks cooled off Anthony Davis he was
exhausted from scoring 45 now we're
doing fine and I hope that the tone of
my voice
you know tells you that things are fine
down here well we can't wait to get you
out here in sunny Southern California
for the all-star game I would love to
get you here in studio in person when
you're out here in Los Angeles area that
would refund oh I wish it I hope we can
do it man because it's always a pleasure
being on your show like minus one out
there thanks thanks thanks Ernie
appreciate it that's Ernie Johnson the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience